was wie geht dieses video allein schon
los what the [ __ ] ja ok aktuell betreibt
ja richtig
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge hacker schau das ist
die vierte folge insgesamt und hacker
schoss ein format in dem ich ein sendung
zeige die e mails schickt also ihr
schickt mir material von hackern zu ich
kommentiere das schaue mir an und latein
für euch hoch die lustigsten
spannendsten und verrücktesten hacker
gibt hier in server zu sehen bevor es
losgeht noch eine anmerkung ich um max
waren letztens kartfahren in der nähe
von köln ist richtig richtig geiles
video rausgekommen ist der erste link in
der beschreibung kann immer abdecken
wenn ihr mal bock drauf habt zu sehen
wer besser kart fährt max oder ich mache
übrigens mein bruder krankhaft ag damit
ist aber okay dann würde ich sagen
gelegen direkt los mit der ersten
sendung die stammt von bushido und
schreibt für es case hacker show zwei
hacker auf die gleich zwei stück und er
meint einer von denen hat wohl
teleporter kann hat die hochgeladenen
stichwort hochladen wie immer leute wenn
ihr mir material zu schicken wollen wenn
ihr vorkommen wollte in der sendung
ladet das videomaterial als ungelöstes
video hoch und schickt man den link dazu
entweder per youtube en oder per e mail
an hkz ausflug punkt.de 3d in haft
lasst uns loslegen gespannt warte mal
deinen chat kleiner junge ok ok direkt
und becker schon aber die wand dann vor
was war das
das geht nicht mal der ender perle leute
okay kein fall schon alles klar
alles
erstmal hier also den chelsea wirklich
kleine machen können bitte macht
kleidern einsendung aber das macht ja
erst einmal richtig stand und jetzt beim
wie geht so was
guck mal hier einfach oben de facto 35
kimi escort
es macht überhaupt keinen sinn und dann
springt darunter kriegt keinen fall
schaden
okay vielleicht ist der fall schon
ausgestellt das kann sein aber man sieht
einfach schon die er läuft so rotter er
hat einfach kein noch beck wie wie macht
man das deutsche schreibt man die
kommentare was für das man ich weiß auch
nicht was das alles jetzt irgendwie der
ender perfekt 3000 feuer bis 3000 tender
perfekt oder wenn ihr es wisst wie immer
gerne in die kommentare
ich will wissen wie immer der disclaimer
ich habe keine ahnung von hacks also
braucht nicht aufregen dass ich kein
hallo von hacks aber das ist
offensichtlich ich bin einfach ganz
maler minecraft spieler und kommentiert
die angst ist unbegründet
eure sommer hier wieder alles klar ein
seiner nummer zwei wieder was ist um
über thailand die erste einzahlung immer
noch von der shadow okay nicht gespannt
hat er den chat kleiner gemacht
nein es steht einfach weniger drin da
habe ich mich dann nur noch weg gesehen
war vielleicht zu weit weg nordberg gehe
alles klar
ok
gutes geld
sorry leute wenn ich so aussah wie
random ist das bitte gebt einfach ab so
warum brennt ihr jetzt aber schnell dass
fremde so bis dahin eigentlich alles
noch relativ normal aus sucht man in
europa abbauen
alles klar oder wie zurück wagt aber so
war es das notieren auf die nächste 1
sendung stand von sodass und hat das
video genannt mega dreister hacker in bw
sogar auf gomez sogar hacker makita
power ups santino beck schreitet er mal
gucken ob das auch wirklich hat das
beste ist erscheint noch an timo beck ag
also altinok tasche hatte riss und
secret engel die anti doping war nicht
so witzig alles klar
gut und fange einfach angst mit papa
papa so weit alles ligety und jetzt das
war leicht selbst aber auswärts am 1
das ist schon leicht seltsam aus aber
hatte und eigentlich zusätzlich
festzustellen jetzt ja ok ja alles klar
ist schon frech ist schon frech aufgabe
komme hat eigentlich ein richtig gutes
know jack plugin oder hot plug in ouchy
plus wurde aber eigentlich ist auch
komme relativ schwer zu hacken oder
nicht also schwerer als auf anderen
servern auf jeden fall des videos
einfach zwölf minuten lang
okay das tier schon wieder auf so hat
wieder mal die mitte denkt sich nichts
böses wieder klassischen auf weg aber
der des lima geflogen man das nicht mehr
geflogen war um kann ziemlich pflegende
studium in der birne
ich will da in der fliegen kann okay
leute nächste 1 sendung stammt von my
mate und er hat scheinbar noch ein
hacker auf dem hd gefunden diesmal ins
chaos
okay was geht dieses video allein schon
los what the [ __ ] ja ok rtl betreibt ja
richtig guck mal hier war kalter wie
dreist sei wirklich heißt es jetzt nicht
so einfach
und er fliegt einfach nur was ist dass
man erfreut wie schnell fliegt man what
the [ __ ] wollte müsste mal gegen dieses
videos die noch beschleunigt alter
schwede
und er schaut einfach also zu von der
plätze wird oder ihm jetzt holt er ihn
häufiger vorweg okay dass das ist halt
nicht mehr dieses terroristen hätten
sondern der krieg wirklich durch die
gegend also den kann marseilles fahrbahn
leute ohne witz ich glaube dass das ist
wirklich der dreisteste flecker den ich
hier gesehen habe schaut euch das mal an
wie er einfach rüber hin und her schießt
man wie schnell vor allem ist er
unsichtbar
ja ich glaube dass man sich doch kein
skin welcher die unsichtbaren gehen
ich weiß es nicht und das ist das ist
schon richtig richtig dreist ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass sowas auf komme geht
ehrlich gesagt so übertrieben krasses
hecken kurs wie schnell der ist das
gibt's doch nicht
er schießt einfach so durch die gegend
und holt sich einfach einen nach dem
anderen
jetzt holt er ihn den aufnehmenden sarg
war war mir sehen wie schnell runter
geht achtung auf die leben hier unten so
dreieinhalb herzen profit wiking zack
zack zack zack zack und er kann es
einfach gar nicht steuern
ja ich glaube das ist das problem er
kann kann einfach selbst ganz einfach
selbst nicht steuern achte mal drauf ich
schieß einfach so dich gegen weil es
selbst gar nicht mehr kontrollieren kann
denn porsche hat sich in portugal
porsche hat direkt aus zuffenhausen
alles klar also sowas auf gomez hat
schon wirklich wirklich dreist ich
bedanke mich fürs zuschauen das war's
von der heutigen folge das gerne
leichter wenn euch das gefallen hat es
gibt jeden sonntag und nachfolger
schauen also schaut einfach sonntags mal
rein
das interessiert das was vor mir ich
wünsche euch einen schönen start in die
woche oder welchen tag immer die mir das
gerät hat rein macht's gut und